now Horowitz report finds at least 17
significant errors and omissions and
Carter pages FISA applications 17 Carter
page joins us now
now how many interviews did I do with
you Carter page and I pressed you I
pushed you I pressed you I said when you
went abroad to rush in these place did
you come back and would you sit with our
intelligence people and give them every
knowledge that they knew yes did you
work for them I don't really want you
dodged and duck didn't you I said to you
I figured it out you work for one of our
agencies all right I take about myself
but then I find out that it was even
more important than that then they
totally they up took a piece of
information about you altered it to say
the opposite basically that you're
betraying your country when you helped
your country absolutely Sean and there's
you know I think he's never lied to me
and I pushed too hard definitely and you
were so far ahead of the story with
chairman Graham congressman Nunez
congressman Jordan the team they really
uncovered so much of this and you told
the American people the truth while the
American people were being told lie
after lie as was very deeply documented
throughout this report today so it's
extremely troubling this is you know
where OPA Tory information about you was
not given to the court if you don't have
a massive lawsuit that will pay you
hundreds of millions of dollars I don't
know who would do you plan on going
after all of these people that did this
to you
absolutely Sean we there is a team of
you know I was always working on this on
my own for the last few years and they
kept giving DOJ run run rings around me
and right now as we speak we have a team
of attorneys going through that document
in great detail and look forward to
sharing that do it with initial thoughts
with chairman Graham and the Senate
Judiciary Committee with our initial
thoughts in preparation you okay Carter
didn't you you you did work for our CIA
you put your life at risk and
foreign countries and you obtained
information that you shared with your
government because you love this country
is that true yes and I typically don't
like to talk about it but clearly again
it's all I pushed you to four hundred
times and you wouldn't answer me tonight
do you feel vindicated partially I mean
you know again I think the words that
senator Cruz says the first step this is
just the very beginning there is so much
more I mean every every page there's
tons of additional information which we
can then provide and I think the the
coming lawsuit will will definitely help
get to the bottom of all you were an
asset for a three-letter agency that put
his life at risk that cooperated with
our intelligence agencies and they
purposely took that out and changed it
to screw you spy on you and take your
civil liberties away sad day yeah well
again you know I mean yeah director race
finished his letter was saying protect
the American people against threats and
up it hold the Constitution
unfortunately it was the absolute
opposite and you know it had I had tons
of death threats related to these false
media reports which were also welcomed
misleading the court I know
Carter page I'm glad you're in the
process now of getting your good name
back but you lost a year of your life
your civil liberties would denied you
thank you for being with us